[Music]
humans have mapped nearly all of the
land on earth
explored the deepest oceans stepped foot
on the moon and sent probes to the
planets and beyond
but there's a whole world that is left
largely unexplored the microbial world
there's an enormous amount of
unidentified microorganisms living
within animals
plants and even our own bodies take the
human gut for example
only about 50 of the microbes are
identifiable the other 50
don't match to anything that we know
about and i would go so far as to say a
substantial fraction of that
is what we would call viral dark matter
viral dark matter is the genetic
material
from viruses that is so different than
sequences of viruses that we know about
that it can't be detected with most
conventional methods
in astronomy dark matter is attributed
to certain gravitational observations in
the cosmos
like the formation of galaxies but so
far it can't be detected
and that's a pretty good analogy for
what we're studying here right
we can't detect it with any of our
reference viruses
but we know it exists we can see it it
has features that are vaguely like a
virus
under a microscope it looks like a virus
but a closer look at the dna sequence
reveals that it doesn't match anything
ever seen before
and so scientists can't confirm what it
is or what it does
and a lot of it is thought to be yet
unidentified viral information
[Music]
hundreds of thousands of unknown viruses
probably
are covering our bodies in our intestine
on our skin in our mouth and and
everywhere else
in fact viruses are the most abundant
biological entity on earth
more than all other organisms combined
but most of them are harmless
some called bacteriophages or phages for
short
infect bacteria that live in us and can
actually be good for your health
in the same way that fluctuating
bacterial populations are
important for our health and well-being
the viruses that infect those bacteria
are of importance as well so viruses
are undoubtedly essential for life as we
know it on the planet and probably
for the persistence of human populations
but there are challenges with
identifying and even categorizing some
of them as viruses
they're so genetically diverse that two
similar looking viruses from the same
family
might actually have almost nothing in
common there's an interesting term
called polyphyletic which means
for example children might want to put
whales and say fish
into the same category but but from the
perspective of evolution
it's very clear that say fish and whales
represent
distinct forms of life that have come to
look similar to each other
through various sorts of forces it may
very well be that some of these
different
viral forms of life are not related to
each other in which case
even using the word virus to link them
all together
might in some ways be misclassification
but identifying and classifying this
stuff could help us understand the cause
of certain cancers
infections and even prevent a pandemic
we have learned for
example that a range of cancers
are caused by previously unknown
transmissible agents whether it be
cervical cancer the vast majority of
which is caused by
human papilloma virus hpv it's also the
case for certain gastric cancers
stomach cancers as we start to uncover
the diversity of living things that have
the potential to infect us or perhaps
even more likely the
sort of bacteria that are so profoundly
important in our microbiome
we have the capacity of identifying
agents that perhaps cause
chronic diseases and that's exactly what
researchers at the national cancer
institute have
they were able to catalog thousands of
new viruses in hopes of aiding human
health
at first the team sampled humans and
animals in hopes of understanding two
specific families of viruses
that are associated with cancer but as
they isolated these viruses they
uncovered many more dna sequences that
hadn't been recorded before
viral dark matter and this is that's
kind of where
all labs are at this point is we go
fishing for the things that we like
and then we get this giant pile of other
things and
it it's not possible for you know one
person to hand curate
5000 entities instead of just ignoring
these new dna sequences
they develop software that makes sharing
new viral dna information easier
called cnotaker which is freely
available online for others to use
it can automatically annotate virus dna
in a way that's compliant with public
databases
making understanding data and sharing
findings easier than ever
now that our tools available they can
easily take their
virus genomes curate them and annotate
them and
share them easily with all the other
researchers and so then
god forbid there is another outbreak or
pandemic it's going to be easy
for researchers to find that sequence in
humans to know exactly where it was
previously and which animals we're
hoping
that that basically by rendering the
dark matter visible
it just makes it so that if there's a
disease association
somebody's going to see it rather than
just ignoring it
although these additional viruses are a
small fraction of the millions of
unknown viruses that are thought to
exist
adding to databases that virologists
share is a small step towards preventing
and treating health issues
i think it's quite exciting that there
is so much that it's unknown
understanding these things has a deep
capacity to help us understand
our origins the nature of what life
is the diversity of forms that life can
exist in
and to help place us in the broader
context
of what it means to be alive
and what our place in the living world
really means
you